this channel is about theories of
everything in the mathematically
rigorous theoretical physics sense but
as well as understanding the role
consciousness has within physics perhaps
even without physics in order to have a
meticulous and comprehensive
understanding of toes then one should
understand or at least attempt to
understand the more experiential eastern
approaches rather than purely the
western analytical one admittingly the
latter is the approach that i'm most
comfortable with which is why i'm in an
extremely lucky and blessed position
since this initial foray into the
eastern area of spirituality is with a h
almas
almas is an eminent and lauded spiritual
advisor who writes about and teaches an
approach to spiritual development
informed by depth psychology and therapy
called the diamond approach in fact
almas is the arabic word for diamond
given that almas holds a phd in physics
this episode serves as a copacetic
introduction both to the regular viewers
of this channel as well as to myself to
the ideas of what at least is
demonically called the east click on the
time stamp in the description if you'd
like to skip this intro my name is
kirchey mungle i'm a torontonian
filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as analyzing consciousness and
seeing its potential connection to
fundamental reality whatever that is
essentially this channel is dedicated to
exploring the under nature of reality
the constitutional laws that govern it
provided those laws exist at all and are
even knowable to us if you enjoy
witnessing and engaging with others on
the topics of psychology consciousness
physics etc the channel's themes then do
consider going to the discord and the
subreddit which are linked in the
description there's also a link to the
patreon that is patreon.com
kurchimongo if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reasons that i'm
able to have podcasts of this quality
and this depth given that i can do this
now full time thanks to both the patrons
and the sponsors support speaking of
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some of the
fundamentals of physics particularly
with regard to information theory as i'd
like to interview chiara marletto on
constructor theory which is heavily
based in information theory now
information theory is predicated on
entropy at least there's a fundamental
formula for entropy so i ended up taking
the brilliant course i challenged myself
to do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge slash uncertainty what i
loved is that despite knowing the
formula for entropy which is essentially
hammered into you as an undergraduate it
seems like it comes down from the sky
arbitrarily and with brilliant for the
first time i was able to see how the
formula for entropy which you're seeing
right now is actually extremely natural
and it'd be strange to define it in any
other manner there are plenty of courses
and you can even learn group theory
which is what's being referenced when
you hear that the standard model is
predicated on u1 cross su-2 cross su-3
those are lead groups continuous lead
groups visit brilliant.org
tow t-o-e to get 20 off an annual
subscription and i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking the second sponsor is algo now
algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce return and
inventory write downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception in
fact amjad has his own podcast on ai and
consciousness and business growth and if
you'd like to support the tow podcast
then visit the link in the description
to see amjad's podcast because
subscribing to him or at least visiting
supports the toe podcast indirectly
thank you and enjoy
so almas why don't you give an overview
to the audience of your diamond approach
for those who are unfamiliar with it and
perhaps if you like you can compare and
contrast it to advaita vedanta but you
may have to give an example of what that
is as well
well
i teach a particular
approach to
actualizing the total human potential
and really what we find out if we
explore the human potential that most of
it is
not conscious it's not the physical and
the emotional that's just the surface
so
a big part of it is the spiritual sphere
and
matter of spirits
so the
teaching is mostly about us is
how to
open up or to access the spiritual
dimension
of our reality for existence
and in my approach i use western
methodology like i use western
psychology for instance i integrate that
as part of the methodology
of how to open up
i use inquiry which is sort of like
similar to socratic
inquiry as a particular method
that for me is more important than
sitting meditation although we employ
sitting meditation too of different
kinds
and the idea is to find out
what the hell are we
what's going on
what am i what am i
what is the word or universe what is the
nature of the universe that's how i
started actually why it started in
science i want to know what is the truth
of reality
so i went
very far
as you know and studying physics and
math until some people realize i wasn't
getting it i wasn't that's not
for me i wasn't getting what where i
wanted to go i didn't know
consciously where i wanted to go
but as i
got deeper into
physics and also
conversing with scientists and
i realized that
it's a it's uh the approach is
good wonderful and very useful i'm
interested in it i love it all of that
and i was good at it
it it was from here up
you know didn't include the heart
didn't include the
other capacities we have
so the approach uses
i use i said uses inquiry but uses the
scientific methods in some kind of way
which means i have it has to be verified
not by experiment as done in physics but
by experience
but one's own direct experience not what
i hear
not what i learn from teaching what i
can verify
and repeatedly
and then can verify in other people
and other people to
which at the beginning were my friends
my students
was that the teaching was developing
so and but it is
what uh what developed is a certain
perspective
about the spiritual dimension
that the spiritual dimension is not just
one thing
it's not like experience consciousness
and you know what consciousness is and
that's it
you see at veda vedanta for instance
is
[Music]
teaching about realization of pure
consciousness
to recognize that
one is that one's true self
is pure consciousness
that
has no limits
no size no shape
and that it is also the nature of
everything
and
that is part of the teaching i i give
but my teaching is not as a little bit
more nuanced i would say
because that has more detail and some
people think of it as more complex
but
because
the
the spiritual dimension for me is not
just one dimension
like consciousness for me is one
dimension
emptiness another dimension which
buddhism emphasizes
love is another dimension
you see
and creative dynamism what makes things
happen
you see
they don't don't they don't
differentiate those that much i mean
they include them in consciousness but
sort of implicitly so
i differentiate into different
dimensions and then those dimensions can
also
express themselves in human experience
and the physics
as particular what i call spiritual
qualities
there was spiritual qualities like the
quality of
clarity
the quality of compassion
uh quality of sincerity
the quality of uh
will
you see steadfastness
and there are many of those qualities i
know at least 40 or 50 of those i i
don't think i know all of them
they're similar to what's called the
platonic
ideas you see in some sense they are the
platonic ideas be behind
what we know like when we say love many
human beings experience love
but what is the platonic idea of love
what is the true
spiritual
counterpart to what a human being called
love and turns out to be a very
particular way of experiencing
consciousness
so
my approach is basically is how to learn
about the spiritual qualities which make
us be able to connect to the spiritual
sphere
which in my work the emphasis is in
presence and
ontological present
the presence of consciousness
not just conscious as uh function of
consciousness as the presence the
beingness of it
and then
connection to the more of the non-dual
which is similar to advaita vedanta
and then
recognize the non-dual has more nuances
and and then connecting the non-dual
with the ordinary life how is it
how how would we leave if we are if i'm
infinite consciousness how do i live a
human life
what lives and how do i live
and that of course
a big part of the spiritual
realization of most teachings you see
and so i teach that too i work with that
but then i i leave the door open
for uh the spiritual universe to reveal
other possibilities because there are
other possibilities of knowing reality
for instance
which really go into it takes us back
similar to some of the physics quantum
theory
you know
household perspective
well
let me
give this example
if you have
a
buddhist master
and vader master
sitting in the same room
the buddha says
nature reality's emptiness and that's
what the experience what the person
experiences emptiness is
the spacious emptiness
is what i experience it is the
fundamental ground
the advaita without the person said
fundamental
nature of reality is pure consciousness
this is conscious of itself
and it's not emptiness it's
characterized by being
while the buddhists say characterized by
non-being
now they're both right in my perspective
but each one of them says this is the
ultimate
so how can they be both alternate
and
in my exploration i find out that
they're both correct
however
if
what is really there is the ultimate
fundamental truth how come people
experience it so differently
and so my
through my own
spiritual investigation the tradition
and my experience and
is that
the
how we experience what is the truth
depends on the experiencer
on the in the person
different people can experience it
differently there are different ways
reality reality manifests
so the experiencer
is what makes reality appear in a
certain way
that brings us to quantum theory
you see the experience that is needed
for the
for the
for the quantum wave to collapse to be
to manifest in a certain way
before that we don't know what it is
so the observer that's what
quantum theory says
here you know it is the experience
similar to that but the experiencer is
experiencing
inward reality instead of experimenting
observing something external
so i i
i look at the spiritual realization as
i have what's called the quantum theory
of spirituality
which is that
that the spiritual
truth
is indeterminate
until we experience it
and how we experience it depending it
depends on our world view our view of
reality
depends on our expectation but it
depends on our readiness and openness
so that for me explains many traditions
while there are so many traditions you
know
different kind of teachings
can you give me an example of this
inquiry process this socratic process
and then also why do you say that in
your approach it holds more of a
preeminent role than meditation
okay i mean i see me i mean i understand
meditation that's how i started myself
learning different kind of meditations
buddhism indian and sufi meditations
but
the way my own experience opened up
is by
knowing my experience in the
moment and
being interested to understand it what
is it what is its meaning
what's it about where does it come from
so that becomes an inquiry
into uh
present experience meditation is not
focused on experience meditation is
focused like the concentration like in
the tibetan you visualize something
and that veda vidante you say it's not
this not this
and i say no it's not nothing i want to
know this what why is it here
what makes it be here what's it about
so i can start with any experience like
an experience of being irritated or a
piece of being
hopeful of something or experience of
inner joyfulness or experience of
sadness
and by by getting injured by feeling it
fully as fully as possible which
requires the development of many
capacities actually because experiencing
something fully is not as simple as most
people
can't experience things fully
most people experience things somewhat
mentally somewhat emotionally
fully i mean your your body is
sensitized completely open your heart is
open your mind capacities are open and
developed and all that so
but you know there are degrees of
capacity for degrees of how capable we
are in engaging this inquiry depending
how open we are how developed we are
but it could begin in the simplest way
by saying well
today i'm feeling
somewhat um
discouraged
finding out why am i discouraged
i'm discouraged that's pandemic is never
over
right
the scene
goes from one thing to another okay
i'm feeling just scary because the
pandemic is not really all just the
pandemic and fun
not just that
that is part of it but then i realized
i'm discouraged because i feel i still
don't feel completely fulfilled
you know i mean it's true there's a
pandemic i can't see some of my friends
and family but there is something inside
me that is not complete
and then i'm inquiring to what is this
feeling we're not being complete not
being fulfilled
now this talking back and forth to
oneself this reminds me of the
relationship a patient may have to a
therapist except one is having it with
oneself and i know that you've said that
you take plenty of inspiration from the
depth psychologist so is this what
you're referring to
we see the cycle it's similar hasn't it
similarity to psychology
but you see a psychologist
wants to heal the patient
here i'm not trying to heal someone i'm
trying to understand it i'm interested
in knowing what it is
i'm not interested in getting rid of the
problem
and are you trying to understand it
without an emotion attached to it or are
you trying to understand it so that
you're happier or so that like what is
the emotion with the understanding are
you supposed to look at it as if it's
words on a paper so that is more
clinically are you supposed to identify
with it
neither of those is complete engagement
in it
you see that's the thing about uh
what brings my perspective of science
is that in in the science
you have to be detached from the
experiment you can't be
you know part of it either the observer
has to be
uh
the more detached the more and engage
the more the experiment is pure you see
and the inquiry in oneself
it includes the subject the observer
so i'm inquiring in both the experiencer
and the experienced
you see they're both there in the field
of experience because and um
so to to really
because inquiring it to oneself and
inquiring into the subject basically
and so as part of it is
psychological
part of it comes from the socratic
method if you remember socrates
would bring his
students and ask them
what is courage
and he says i don't know let's find out
what is courage
why are they exploring courage not
because they want to be courageous they
want to first find out what it is do
they do i know it or don't i know it if
i know it what's it like
so that's that's a socratic part here
so it is not it's not aim
yeah it's not aim not aim oriented
so because the
impetus
and this teaching
is not
the
or let's say the drive for enlightenment
it's not a matter of being free from
suffering or from problem
but it is love for the truth
love to know the truth as completely as
fully as possible
earlier when you were referencing that
the buddhist may emphasize emptiness and
then someone else may emphasize pure
consciousness and someone else may
emphasize love and so on and so on are
these all unified in some manner
they're unified in this and they're all
coming from
the same place
but not unified you see some
advaita vedantiform they think they're
unified because they're all
consciousness they're all consciousness
and all you know
manifestative consciousness and that
emptiness is
one of the manifestation of
consciousness we just would disagree
with that will think consciousness
arises out
of emptiness you see
my understanding of it
is that the actual truth is
indeterminate
just like quantum theory until you
experience it
it's not set when people want to want
the certainty or the security
of feeling the
truth of what i am
is here and i just need to discover it
that is how many spiritual teachings say
it is here you just need to open up
waking up to it
and my what i discovered through my
exploration is that
the truth is here but not manifest
it's not just a matter of discovering it
i need to be ready and interested and
open and then it will appear
where will it come from
doesn't come from anywhere
it just comes
it just appears
so what what is that what do we say
where does it come from
i say it's unknown unknowable
now is that unknown sorry is that
unknown unknowable
yeah okay now is that unknown unknowable
what most religions are trying to
conceptualize when they use the word god
or is that different or is that does
that predate god
yes and the
monotheistic tradition think
god is unknown unknowable that's how
christianity judaism and islam take that
god you cannot know god as god that's
what they say
the mystic like the sufi is they say you
could
unify with god you can be one
with god and you know the god's being
but that doesn't mean you know
everything about god
so god and
ask god from perspective god is not
known
i don't think of the truth myself as a
god
i mean maybe some people think of it as
god i don't because god being killed us
into the creator this and that
and for me
things are more interesting and subtler
than that
that i am something
unknown unknowable i know i am i know
what i am
but i don't know i cannot say what it is
but i can say a lot
about myself
that expresses that
like awareness and consciousness and
love and spaciousness and emptiness and
all of that
what is the ego ideal
yeah so that's from the book and the
the enneagram book the ego idea
but that's normal psychology freudian
psychology that each ego has an ego idea
has an ideal which means it is
constructed around
some kind of idea of how you want to be
what kind of person you want to be
what kind of life you want to have
so your ideal is to be a sort of a
successful person or your ideal to be
really
more of a helper
idea of being authentic or original
you see these are ideal around that that
each ego has that
that
goes back all the way back to freud you
see
but i use it as
when i
work with the enneagram knowledge
and i see the
different types
as each is a manifestation of a
particular ego ideal
what's the difference between awakening
and realizing
or realization
you see many teachers won't make a
distinction
for me i do make a distinction
and
some do
but i'm not the only one who does
is that what you awakening first of all
there are different kind of awakening
you know if you read grejie for instance
his first awakening he says the terror
of the moment to realize i am asleep
i don't know who i am
most people aren't awakened that way yet
to know i don't know who the hell i am
what am i what's meaning in my life why
am i here
that's the first awakening
for grade the second awakening is to
know
to
what you are to erupt into consciousness
but you know i'm
pure
spirit that is aware and conscious of
itself
now for me realization
means that has become
your true self it has become a constant
um
constantly integrated
it's not just
you know it you
woke up to it you know you know i
experienced it
what about wisdom
so you're curious about many things
you see
you know buddhists talk about wisdom and
certain way
you know but i think of it more in a
western way wisdom
you know and if you're a buddhist who is
the me knowing what emptiness is
for them they call that wisdom if you
really know from an experience
what is empty what is the emptiness of
self
what is the emptiness of everything they
call that wisdom
for me and wisdom is more practical
which is
as i know myself as i know um
my true self or my spiritual nature or
my
true nature usually
and
and i
um
not know what have integrated it
and then
how i live it how i live my life is
living from that place
and living from that place being able to
live in that place
in response to the work the world the
world situation i find myself in
so that my response to the situation i'm
in
comes
informed and expressing
what i have learned what i am now
and that becomes a spontaneous and
natural and very appropriate
way of dealing with the situation that
appropriate and full way of dealing with
situation is wisdom knowing how to deal
with life situation from the spiritual
perspective including spiritual
perspective without denying the material
perspective for me is to be wise
that's as you know that's how
western philosophy was the religion
what wise president why is it not just
you can be yourself is how you live in
the world
you have to live wisely
does that make sense for you let me see
if i'm understanding this so the second
awakening because you refer to number
one and number two the second awakening
is more about the perception of a
particular insight than realization is
the persistence of that insight
and then wisdom is the conformance
between one's action and that insight
or is in my office that's a good way of
saying it
yes
but uh the only addition i will say is
not just insight
is being
that
discovery like i discover
that my nature is a pure presence
which is a sense of being sense of
existence
that does not exist in my body it's pure
existence
i am
you see like
i am but i am
is the
palpable sense
of uh
public sense
of consciousness conscious of its own
uh being it's because consciousness is
not a function consciousness is a
reality
consciousness is something that is
and when consciousness knows itself
awakes to itself as oh that is what i am
i am this kind of luminous
aware presence aware of myself and can
be aware of other things
that will be
the realization
see the way that i'm wondering about
this is akin to a tree with branches
that all come from the same root and
then when one says that consciousness
realizes itself well let's imagine that
you're an example of that i don't
imagine that i'm an example of that so
just because you have found that out
even though at least in this model we're
all part of the same route it seems
localized to you it doesn't seem to
spread outside of your teachings and
helping people so the way that i'm
visualizing it is like a branch and then
there's a loop on that branch and that
is what is occurring when you say
consciousness realizes itself rather
than when consciousness realizes itself
another way of thinking of that is all
these branches just intertwined at once
but i and probably some of the people
who are listening just because you or
some of the other people have had
insights or have had these realizations
of consciousness
realizing itself it doesn't mean they
have like for example i don't think i've
had it so how does that comport is it
that it is a separate branch because i'm
trying to understand this with the other
teaching that we're all the same in some
manner and so how is it that if you have
an insight and it's i don't have that
insight automatically
most people don't have that insight and
don't have the capacity for that insight
it's not easy to have that kind of
insight
it it has to do with some kind of
maturations of one's uh
consciousness one's being on
subjectivities
and
development of
one's heart so that the heart has
developed to the point where there is
the natural
desire to know what i am
that becomes a force
that opens up things
and most people are
are more busy with survival and
jobs and families you know they don't
have the opportunity to or
enhance even the interest to devote to
this kind of
exploration so it is a very specialized
thing in some sense that's why
you know all around the world people who
realize they're not that many the few
you know and um
because but it is a potential for all of
us
because we all have the spiritual nature
as our nature we have to say all of us
have the same nature
and that's one thing when insight we we
learn
when i discover i remember you know
years ago
when i first discovered the
experience presence oh i am i am i know
what i am
and i then felt
connected to all human beings
i felt i am as this
conscious presence i'm connected with
all human beings because all human
beings are
have that same
presence the same
inherent
uh truth to them
so that showed me potential for
everybody
everybody can experience it
at some point you know if they dedicate
themselves to it or they happen to be
somewhat open or mature or have had the
right influence in their life you know
there are many factors
you're right that
you know
just because i say this is my experience
that's right that doesn't mean i'm
assuming others experiencing that way so
everyone does have the capacity or not
everyone does
everybody has the potential
but not the capacity not necessarily the
capacity you know what's the difference
between those two
potential is
is what you are capacity is capacity of
perception capacity of subtle perception
and different kind of
perception different kind of way
different kind of consciousness that
than we know
most human being are aware of
consciousness and i see and hear and
have emotions and sensation all of that
but all of those uh
you know perceptual uh
organs have their spiritual counterpart
which i call subtle counterpart there's
inner seeing there's inner sensing
there's inner feeling that is not
thought
those are the outer expression of it
so one can
some of us have some of those subtle
things but we're not aware of them so we
don't employ them
but some it requires development and and
that is what what i see the wrong
meditation
meditation helps in developing some of
those capacities
should everyone have these realizations
like if you had a magic wand and you can
wave it do you think it's for everyone
or do you think it's for certain people
at a certain time or perhaps not for a
particular person at any time
the reason behind this question is that
i'm sure you've seen this in some
spiritual teachers they think that
everyone should be enlightened awakened
and they may even use words like
like you've used with development though
i don't think you meant it in this way
but as if the enlightened is higher than
someone else which then implies a
looking down at people who aren't
enlightened
well i mean spiritual teaching all
they have a teaching to help people to
access
a realm of reality that they're usually
not
accessing
so obviously they think it's there's a
value in that
and and having that openness that's
capacity for
subtle access
and uh but
i wouldn't say that any teaching will
will say
everybody should
it's not matter should it's more like
it's possible or everybody everybody has
a possibility
when it will happen for somebody
it's something magical something sort of
uh like a destiny of sort
so
i
i think it would be great if more people
are like that
you know because that will sort of move
the human race in terms of becoming more
human because really
uh that's another point that's important
occurred which is the more we are in
touch with our spiritual dimension the
more human we are you see people don't
know that most people know think i am
human i i am human because i have a body
human body i have a human emotion i can
think or i'm rational that makes me
human
for the sufis for instance they say no
no that's not human yet
to be truly human you have to have true
hearts
which mean a heart that can converse
with the divine
that makes me human a human you see
for the sufis is the bridge between the
divine and the physical world
and if you're not that bridge yet you're
sort of on the way to being human but
you're not totally human yet
so uh many people
and it is not looked at as
gradation or or
one is better than other it's more like
a natural process like evolution
you know evolution happens in different
ways and
different areas and
different different ways
so we all human being can evolve
you know we evolved physically and
mentally
we can evolve spiritually too
and it is
it's hard to tell where it's going to
happen like when my students you know
come to me i don't know which one is
really going to go deeper than the other
you know
sometimes surprised for some people
after a while they seem to be
they can't go deeper and suddenly
something happens and they're you know
they surprised me how wonderful they
seem to know themselves you know
how in their
start to experience themselves in a way
that's about liberating
so i wish it for a human being because
it has less suffering in it
it has
more the
enjoyment of discovering reality i mean
you know you're a scientist
you know scientists explore
through science
you're not exploring so i could develop
something to sell or for because i'm
you know
given a grant and i have
pure sciences like you you want to
discover because you enjoy the discovery
the exploration
so
when one is awakened
you the discovery becomes the way we
live our life we're having discoveries
all the time and discover about what i
am what is life what is it how a thing
can be done in a way that makes it more
real more total
and it's wonderful way to live
you see it brings in more dimensions to
exist to life so definitely i wish it
for people but i'm not think everybody
should i mean it's up to the people
themselves what happens inside them
i don't for because of that in my school
i don't go i'll try to get students
i don't
i don't try to convert anybody and
it's ridiculous for me to do that it's
more like
i just
hear and i make
something
a point in
showing that i'm here and that's what i
do
and who's interested will will come you
see
and they can learn
what i can teach
so and
so although i wish it for a human being
to be
more themself
more complete for everybody for
everybody wishes forever making me it
wouldn't mean they'll be happier deeper
more fulfilled that's what it means
you see
but do i say that everybody should
well some people are just that's not
what's happening in their life
they're
busy getting married or having kids or
something like that who am i to say no
you should
come here focus then meditate first you
know
standing this twin concept of we should
value this or sorry forget about [ __ ]
this is more valuable this approach of
being enlightened or realizing or
awakening and so on and of course and
being wise is more valuable but on the
other hand we should not or we don't
want to talk about should and i from my
cursory examination of the more eastern
practices it's as if they have a phobia
they're afraid of saying should they
don't want to talk about should but they
can talk about value and i don't to me
those two are tied so can you help
disentangle them
no i think most path most pressure path
they do have a shirt there's not they
don't say it as i should but they say
they advise people yes
you should you know that'll be a good
thing for you to do
but
usually a
really wise
teacher
will see when they meet people who is it
who it is
their time to learn that who isn't
because it's it has to do with timing it
has to do with circumstances
so
although it is
valuable but
the first thing has to come first people
have to establish a life
that's the hindu model as you know first
you become a householder you're married
and then you go and find the teacher
that's how they've done that you see
and not all of them because go and find
the teachers
yes this i've heard you mentioned and i
happen to like it you mentioned in one
of your talks that most spiritual
teachers for lack of a better word
emphasize awakening and then you said
well what are you talking about most
people should feel compassion and love
and security
and to me this is an important point
it's one that i mentioned on not me this
but it's one that came up on a previous
episode with carl fristen and you seem
to be one of the teachers that i see
emphasize this or at least bring it up
though you don't call it this but this
notion of path dependence in physics
which is that it's not about this
destination the destination also depends
on where you are and then how you're
going to get to it in the condition of
the world so to make a blanket statement
and say one should be enlightened and so
on and i see this perhaps you do too
maybe you don't but i see this in
different comment sections of different
videos and online
with people saying you're already lost
if you are in the scientific mindset
you've already lost or you will never
realize x until you follow some path
that i'm telling you and
when i read that
it's not as if it's directed to me i'm
seeing it on other sites but when i read
that i see that as
a spiritual form of
it's like spiritual superciliousness or
arrogance where they and it also puts
undue pressure on people
to
to
perhaps perhaps one should accept
the the position
other people are and
i i think you i agree with you currently
but i think
some of those stories are taken out of
context
meaning
saying you're lost
and
you're not getting it
it is a methodology methodology it is
when a teacher tongue to a student
interacts with a student
to have an impact on them in a certain
way sometimes you have to say that
but not for everybody
you see it's not i wouldn't say that
about somebody who's not my student none
of my business i don't know
obviously but if one of my students is
sort of says come to me and say i want
to learn this but then they don't do it
they do something else or they go off on
some kind of tangent i would tell them
you see you know you're lost you don't
know what you're doing
you're wasting your life you see
and that would make an impact and make
them then
recommit
to that what they said they wanted
i see the way that you're describing it
is much more compassionate loving
amiable approach than some of what i see
and i'm not and you're not this i'm just
saying that this is some of what i see
with people adamantly claiming it
exclamation points as if they're
fearfully commenting about how one
should never feel fear and there's a bit
of derision in it too there's a bit of
yeah oh look at you you little oh little
one you have no idea and i'm the one
that understands this and if you only
could see it from my point of view
there's a bit of condescension in that i
don't think i don't think the buddha
would have talked like that
you know but i agree with you there are
people who talk like that but that's
you see
to be spiritually realized you're
naturally compassionate and
loving
and compassion and
includes atonement
appropriateness
can you expound another attunement i
mean attunement means
i relate to a human being depending on
who and where they are what they are
what they're into what their interests
with their orientation i'm not you know
i'm attuned to it and i speak to that i
i don't just lay on my
value system on them
and that
if somebody doesn't express themselves
that way
i will question their realization
great this is something that i've
wondered too because it's difficult for
me as someone who's being introduced to
this in many ways to discern who is
enlightened from who is not and what
that word means and one of the rules of
thumb or the litmus tests that i use i
encourage people to send me their
theories of everything that's the name
of the channel
and
one of the reasons is i don't know what
is true so let me see even what is
ordinarily considered to be fringe or
woo
perhaps it's not because today's science
was 100 years ago
and so on though i see sometimes people
they're not as humble and tentative as i
believe that they should be when they're
presenting their toe for example their
their spiritual theory of everything you
see yeah
the way i understand spiritualization
the spiritual realization if somebody
has realized
their expression in the world
should come through what's called the
virtues
the you know the ending grounding
which is like humility
serenity
courage
you
know um
love
things like that
if somebody doesn't express themselves
that way what are they expressing you
know so then is that okay when i am
trying to make a quick assessment
because there are probably 1 000
theories of everything and it's
difficult when each person is putting up
their hand saying i have the toe you
have no idea i have the you don't
understand i can't even be wrong is one
of the ways that i could perform a
cursory yes or no to investigate further
is if are they being inimical and
boisterous and pushing it and if so
perhaps that's that implies a bit of
attachment and fear and maybe they lack
an understanding of how to come across
lovingly if one has to thrust one's toe
then
it's it's a different stage you see we
haven't gone to all the stages yet there
is a realization after realization there
is what i call actualization
actualization is what you ends up being
in wisdom actualization mean you live
what you realized you don't just
experience it
that is another stage of development it
doesn't automatically happen through
awakening and realization
earlier when we were talking about
wisdom i would have equated wisdom and
that definition of actualization so are
those two different in your mind
yeah i i agree with you they are similar
thing yes
and so that's interesting because to me
i've seen wise people who wouldn't claim
to have any of these insights so that
means that one can be wise without being
realized and one could be realized
without being wise and at least for me
as this creature who's still perhaps
asleep i tend to prefer the wise i tend
to prefer the wise just because the wise
they're more loving i heed their message
you seem extremely wise and i don't know
am i wrong to prefer that [ __ ] or should
i have no preference with regard to this
it's just it's so difficult for me to
tell which messages are correct the
dalai lama to me exudes compassion and
serenity yes and he is humble too
right saying i'm still practicing i'm
still learning
yes he's not commenting with
yeah within a moderate use of
capitalization
you know
he doesn't do that you know that's
that's that's the real wisdom
that's why i like roger penrose
you like
you know i like it right
because
his relationship to his theories is like
that
like his he talked about his theory of
consciousness as you know
he has his theory of consciousness with
that he has developed other microtubules
and all that but then
he says well
will you say that this read the truth
he'll say well no i think we are
very far away from knowing what
consciousness is
so he sees it as
his contribution toward going that way
he doesn't see that's it while many
other people have fear of consciousness
they think that's it
i remember meeting you know one time
with several
scientists and neuroscientists who each
one has their theory of consciousness
one of the major fears of consciousness
and we had you know we had some kind of
confidence whatever but at some point we
met privately and we were trying to say
how we're going to communicate those
field consciousness and make them more
accept acceptable to a
larger scientific community
and i remember discussing it with them
and
and one of my ideas that each one has a
theory and very different you know
and we're all good
and
and i said well you know to really
the scientific community because it's a
consensus kind of science where we have
and
you
you you can't just
give a big theory with all kind of
assumptions and all kind of unknown
thing and expect the scientific
community to adopt it easily i said why
not just give little thing at a time you
know
put one thing in a small thing and
see how people respond if it is more
accepted then you can add more
they all refused
they said no i want to put out my theory
everybody wanted their theory to be it
because
so part of it is hobros part of what i
think is sort of arrogance as you say
but part was apparently human nature
partly is like i want to be right you
know
each one is convinced that they're right
that's why i say i like project patrol
he's not convinced he's right
he knows his approximation
many of the others don't believe that
they think they got it
i want to tell you about an experience i
had
so
some people say and i don't maybe i
won't include this in the in the final
so i'll try and be quick but some people
say
don't be so be open-minded but not also
open-minded that your head falls out i
don't like that phrase because to me i
like being
because to me the phrase so open-minded
that your head falls out means that
they've already placed a limit and if
i'm investigating this whole field and i
don't know what's true i can't already
say no to this i have to investigate it
and give it its due
so i tend to take
i i think i tend to take on these
theories of everything a bit too
seriously and i would have never said
that before i would have said
so here's an example when i was
interviewing someone named thomas
campbell who has my big toe
he in his book which firstly it's a
it's like three bibles his one book
so i was like okay let me read all of
that let me give it its due it's called
toe it's called my big toe and then
second he said you need to meditate for
at least three months in order to fully
get this so i'm like okay before i
interview i'm going to meditate i'm
going to try this
and
and i do this with almost each guest
however
about three or so weeks ago i had
i had an experience that was probably
the most terrifying experience of my
entire life the more more terrifying and
i've had some terrifying experiences
before
i
and it wasn't on uh psychedelic though
it could be induced by something like
that which we can talk about afterwards
it was an experience i was in bed with
my wife and my
and i thought i i just had this real
could i be all that is like solipsism
and that and i but and i've always
entertained solipsism or i would have
said i entertained it but i analytically
entertained it and that was the first
time i experientially entertained it and
it was the most terrifying thought i'm
still recovering from it like even
talking with you i'm
some of what you say
triggers me some of what anyone in the
spiritual teaching say trigger me right
now because i'm hypersensitive from that
moment it's almost like ptsd it's so
it's too recent and it was so terrifying
that
it was so absolutely terrifying to call
it a panic attack would be like i would
have prayed for five panic attacks
rather than that i see
that's how you call it terrifying yeah
yeah yeah absolutely and i remember
so this is the part that i may take out
so whoever ever is editing this yeah
contact me and then i'll tell you what
to keep in it what to keep out i
i i'm i'm extremely open to god and i
would have never said that before
because i'm atheistic until about two
years ago or three years ago
however that was the only time in like i
was on i felt like i was on the brink of
insanity that there if i had realized
that i would be in the mental hospital
thinking that i have the truth but
everyone else putting me it was so to
look at my wife and think is this a
creation in my head how ungrateful am i
how selfish am i that i would think that
how embarrassed am i but at the same
time that could be real oh my gosh
looking at her and thinking that she's
looking at me from her point of view
behind her eyes like i love my husband
but then to for her to even think is my
husband my husband doesn't think i'm
real what the heck anyway then then
a commanding voice came to me a command
commanding commanding voice and i don't
want to talk about this this is why i
may want to take this out but and it was
more certain than any single thing in my
entire life and it was this commanding
voice that said kurt i don't even
remember what it said but part of it was
kurt you you've developed your thought
so much you don't you don't think of
yourself as someone who's analytical
you're extremely analytical look at what
this has led you to
feel more ground yourself in this world
and that the belief in this world the
belief in the reality of this world is
the same as belief in me it's the same
you don't see how it's the same right
now and that's fine but it is the same
so by you even feeling this solipsistic
experience it's it's almost like a slap
in the face to me that was the only
thing that kept me
grounded was this
deep profound belief anyway i wanted to
tell you about that experience i know
whoever's editing this is gonna have
such a huge time our time but but can
you let me know what you think and how
you would how you approach this
you know i i remember having similar
experience to yours
one time i remember
some years ago
i got up
woke up from sleep woke up my wife was
leaving with me and told her you know
you're a figment of my imagination
because that's how i was experiencing it
i think but that is
one way of experiencing things which
we could call a syllabicistic
but
you know
in the morning i i was still
experiencing that i am everything how i
i at the same time
my wife is real
she has her own experience
so
and
and then you talk about god and i'm i
mean i use the
language of god sometimes divine or god
and sometimes calls spiritual nature
true nature which is or the ground the
spirituality
um
but it is
i think you were into something and you
call it solipsism but i mean that's
that's what
all advaita vedanta is about
that
i
the person realizes i am consciousness
and the caution is evidence so i am
everything
everything is appealing in my mind but
it's not the individual mind is the
the big mind the
uh
you know the boundless the infinite
consciousness
everything is in that and so if we take
it as our individual mind that that can
bring in
the question of solipsism
how can one like myself who was
extremely terrified of that
individualistic mind not come to that
conclusion like what can i do to feel
ease because even you talking about this
right now i feel almost like i'm about
to have a panic attack in some way or a
hang of anxiety but at the same time i
don't want you to ah see this is so
tricky because i feel like by saying
that you're feeling that you felt the
terror i mean i felt terror many times
and and the terror is the transition
from one dimension to another there is
always a terror because you don't know
what's going to happen your whole world
is going to disappear
you don't know what's going to take its
place
and and for me for the spiritual path
for special practice and inquiry
especially
is to welcome the terror and understand
it let it be
as one natural response to what's
happening
integrated
what helped me
which was the only thing that helped me
was i was looking up i think that what i
had was or at least what i started to
suffer from afterward was obsessive
thoughts that this was what i would just
i would look around and i'd be
de-realized i wouldn't feel like this
was all real at all and then i looked up
what does cognitive behavioral therapy
have to say about this and there's
something called acceptance therapy
where you accept the thought rather than
trying to avoid and run from it however
acceptance is not the same as allowing
it to be true it's different and i don't
know how to articulate the difference
but it's it's almost like saying okay i
accept that i may think this and i just
accept but i don't entertain
no i think you you are trying to
put into words
something that is not mental
when you say acceptance i use the word
acceptance but but really acceptance and
the spiritual
as a quality of pure consciousness
is not saying yes to something
it is being
as allowing it to be
without rejection and without acceptance
so it's in the non-rejection
so acceptance acceptance doesn't mean i
take it on as true and that's it no
except i mean let it be as it is
let's find out what it is
you know and let it show itself
you see
i i don't accept and i don't reject what
what i experienced
and
that yeah go ahead
can you tell me about that story about
the man who had a stash of water
and
he felt like the main water source was
vitiated and so he didn't want to drink
from it
can you tell that story and the moral
behind it
yeah yeah
when the waters were changed that's
what's it called that's a sufi story i
think i don't know
it's origin
but that um
what i remember is that a
man who was living in some kind of a
village or something and and
and i don't remember
the part where he realized
that
the water is going to be changed once
you get changed people drink from it
they'll forget who they are
so he collected some of the water for
himself
you see
before it changed
and then people were drinking the water
they all became sort of forgot who they
are he was still awake
but then you said that the point was
that
it was too much for him
well and then there is the quality yeah
how how is he going to live by himself
he he knows reality and everybody else
or i think reality is something else
so he chose to drink from the main
source afterwards uh yeah that's the
story's either he couldn't handle it the
need went and drank the new water
see i think this is part of what
is also
can be dangerous about some spiritual
teachings is that there's the social
pressure that seems unacknowledged
because we use terms like they couldn't
handle it and then we culturally have a
norm that no you should be able to
handle so-and-so so if you can't handle
it there's something wrong with you i
constantly say this that i'm not a truth
seeker i'm a truth seeker of how much i
can handle and i'm a coward
because i'm afraid of what could be true
but at the same time i used to feel
extremely bad about that i used to until
about three weeks ago when i say you
know what kurt
that's how you are that's it that's fine
just accept it i don't think that i'm
one of those people that's meant to have
that realization wow i think
i don't know about that you see i i
myself see that many people
will be afraid to see certain truths
most people will be afraid of seeing
that it will be terrifying for them
but i don't think that that doesn't make
me think i don't want to talk to them i
don't relate with them as equals and i
have friends
i mean many of my friends are
you know people don't not know me don't
understand don't know who i am they
don't see
me as me the way i know myself it's fine
with me
and i don't have a judgment of them
everybody
is everybody has sort of
let's say a line of evolution for them
that is sort of part of their destiny
part of their you know
well what's
happening in their soul and
people are different that way
so i mean you come back to this whether
there is a judgment whether there is a
hierarchy
you know right
and it's true i mean spiritual teaching
sometimes they do have hierarchy of
different stages for instance
in the path but that that is in the path
itself if you are on the path on the
spiritual school there are stages
and some teaching have stages something
you don't
but that doesn't mean the wise
the wise of that school are judging the
people outside of their school as you
know
unless then or anything like that
i think that i was far too egotistical
before in my adoption of theories of
everything by thinking that i could find
the truth and i could have these
realizations if they're in fact
realizations like i would investigate it
but now i think that my contribution
is to help others with their journey one
step rather than taking them all the way
and taking myself all the way i think
i've been humbled by this experience so
humbled in the humiliating sense in the
hurtful sense but in the salutary sense
too that i think my role is to not have
realizations at least right now
and to perhaps if it's anything positive
maybe i can help other people with the
putting on one foot forward you already
had some you just told me about
something you experienced you had
and it just brought fear and the fear is
not metabolized
if if you metabolize the fear
then
you might be able to have that
experience and have more understanding
of how it fits
the rest of your life
because of time constraints we're now
jumping directly from audience question
to audience question john muniz asks
many spiritual teachers and traditions
have disparaged the role of intellectual
development in book learning on the path
of awakening however this person's a fan
of yours and says as as you almas you
try to combine the quest for spiritual
awakening with the quest for mental
understanding i look up to you
since you've managed to integrate those
two domains can you speak about the
positive contribution intellectual
growth can make toward deepening one's
relationship with reality
especially one's initial awakening
more spiritual teaching actually
they begin with some kind of
intellectual understanding
so just learning what is the view which
is the perspective of the teaching
and it is good to have that
but you don't want to stop with that you
want to have the experience not just
until they can understand but you see
the question of the role of the
intellect is a very big question
because
it's not whether you begin with
intellectual understanding which many
teaching
subscribe to
it's
some teaching they think
the mind is a problem at some point
that you need to drop the mind
because what you want is a direct
immediate
experience that is not
constrained by the concept of the mind
and and i think that is true
however
the mind can develop too
the mind is not just one level
you see it's not in the intellect you
know i i remember reading the greek
philosophy you know some of the greek
philosophers like
neoplatonist they had 11 love levels for
for intellect
11. no i didn't know that
yeah the other one in the process i
think
you know
what are some of these levels
well like the usual mind that we usual
intellect we have that we use for
reasoning or whatever and there is
another intellect that
can have capacity for synthesis
you know and then another the capacitive
synthesis that does not depend on
analysis
and then then an intellect that is
illuminated by light
and then there is an intellect that
where
true
intelligence the prototype of
intelligence the platonic form of
intelligence pure intelligence of
spirit flows in the mind
and so that that kind of intelligence
usually people say a person is brilliant
right
when they say when they're smart
why do they say that why do they say
person's brilliant why do they use the
word project do you ever think about it
no
why do they say brilliant
because pure intelligence
when you see it with the subtle sense it
looks like pure brilliance
like you know the brilliance of light
it is brilliance without a color just
pure brilliance and so presence like of
of a palpable
uh
substance
of brilliance
and this brilliance when you when when
your experiences feel like pure
intelligence
it can flow through the mind but also
can flow through the body so we can be
physically intelligent and brilliant
could be emotions
so there's another that's another level
of intellect where where it is open
where the
true intelligence of of spirit
can
come through
the
understanding the capacity for
understanding
and i think that's why
penrose when he talks about
you know
about the consciousness and what it is
that is not
computational whatever
he uses he he goes to and he said
understanding cannot be it's not a
computational thing
but he
he doesn't have he he knows that but he
doesn't exactly know what he knows
the way i see it in the sense he knows
it is not commutation it is not analytic
that understanding is something that
happens within us
that brings out a new experience and new
insights but we don't know
what did it how it worked
because in italy because he is i think
he has that kind of brilliance flowing
in him he might not see it but
it is flowing in him
and and and
so he said he is a materialist he's not
mystical whatever
i think he is
sort of
sort of a mystic without
sort of wanting or wanting to admit that
there is that part of him
something in him because
by saying that understanding not
computational is already is a mystical
insight
because that is a level of intellect
that kind of understanding
when you say that he understands but
without knowing he understands do you
mean that when he's using in that
argument that our mind is not
computational because we understand an
argument that has some gerdelian
argument that he uses the word
understanding but he doesn't understand
what the word understanding means is
that what you mean or something
different no he he doesn't
no i'm not saying he knows what
understanding mean he just doesn't know
why it is not computational
he he doesn't have the uh
i mean i don't know what to say he
doesn't he he sort of has an intuition i
think
that i understand he he put three words
i remember consciousness understanding
and
intelligence he said those three are
related and and all of them are outside
of the computation
i was watching one of your talks and you
were referring to i am that i am which
is statement from what god was saying
when asked for his name and then you
related that to strength knowing
strength or strength somehow to strength
do you mind expounding
well
i am
the sense of
say i am
which is known by many
spiritual teachings
is to know one's
the presence of one's
spirit or one's pure consciousness
and that
which means the ontological
uh
dimension of consciousness
it's ontology not its uh functionality
you see
because most people know consciousness
as a functional thing i'm aware of this
i see that but what is consciousness
itself most people don't even think of
that when you know what consciousness is
that is its ontology
and that feels as some kind of presence
but that then that is i am
however the i am can appear in with
different uh
qualities can appear as pure
not just a pure
presence of
just simply i am
but i am strength meaning the
presence can manifest one of its
possibilities which is pure strength or
pure
one of the insights that i had during my
episode if we can call it that and this
was being told to me is that if what i'm
experiencing isn't loving
isn't somehow life affirming then see
that as a sign that it's deception
so move toward what's loving and ground
myself in other people and talk to them
and so on
what do you make of that do you see that
as having an element of truth
yeah i think yeah i would say is the
truth and love tied and if so how
very much connected because truth is the
essence of the heart
and expresses itself as love
that's my experience of it you see truth
is the essence of the heart and it
expresses itself as love so the
expression of truth is love
yeah
so if somebody is not loving
meaning they're not completely open in
their heart
and the truth of who they are is not
coming through
you had a phrase about
that the
mouth tastes what's material so i'm
butchering it but the mouth tastes
what's material and the heart tastes
what's spiritual
right
well that's some teachings like the sufi
think of a spiritual insight a spiritual
knowledge as taste
but it is the taste of the heart
that the heart is the organ of spiritual
taste
so the knowing
of spiritual matters they think of it as
a heart knowing
and and they
they call it taste
and taste you know
the arabic word
which means
like when you sample something you want
to taste it
you know this sometime means the
capacitive taste but sometimes taste
this
right
so when you have a spiritual experience
you're tasting something
so the heart tastes that
that way
so it get it to get get to know
the the the truth the reality the
spiritual reality
so it's sometimes called taste sometimes
called touch too
and not touch
at some point i want to speak to ken
wilbur perhaps in a few months when i'm
strong enough to
and i know that ken wilbur and you have
agreements and disagreements and i'm
unsure of his model but can you tell me
where you both agree and disagree
like compare and contrast
uh
it's maybe very hard for me to say that
because i haven't been following his
latest things you know and i was
following you or sometimes
but it's it's not a agreement
disagreement
i remember at one time there was some
disagreement some years ago
when
i was
putting out in some of my books
that as
young children
we were in touch with our spiritual
nature
and he disagreed with that he thought no
children are like monsters they're not
in touch with the spiritual nature
and i said yeah
they can be monsters but also they can
be beautiful and wonderful and joyful
and innocent and all of that and these
are spiritual qualities that was you
know this agreement we had at that time
and um
i don't know at the present time i mean
he he is more
of a
philosopher of a systematizer of
of you know
of ways of experience and knowing and
life and all of that and
he's much more that way than i i am and
i'm not engaged in things the same way
he is i think ken will agree with me
that self-reflection the stage
development of humanity and there is
other stages like
immediate knowing
it sounds to me from what you said
earlier about the human actually i don't
know if this is from a talk i believe
this is from a talk about humans
infinite potential and that we're at a
privileged place as humans because of
our ability to self-reflect and who else
would know god if there were no humans
let's assume that there are no other
highly intelligent living creatures and
so on but that statement seems to agree
with what ken said the reason is that if
we go back to childhood we have less
self-reflective capabilities some people
may say much like you had the
disagreement that children can be closer
to god in some ways but then if we take
that further the less reflective
cognitive capabilities that we have the
more we're like the worms and the
beetles and so on so the fact that we
would say or the fact that you said in
the
human infinite potential conference or
talk that we're at a privileged place
seems to to me to indicate that actually
yes we're somehow somewhere
higher
on the spiritual development scale than
children so that's why i was saying that
it sounds to me like you actually agree
with ken from what i understood of your
lessons in that other lecture am i
understanding that incorrectly
but but you're you're putting two things
together that i don't do
which are you talking about
self-reflective capacity
which is true it's a development that
human human being has and we don't have
it as little babies we don't have
self-reflection
however when you are in a realized place
the most realized
condition is not self-reflective
does not reflect on itself
because when it reflects itself there's
nothing
there it
can only look forward
but the point i want to say is that when
i say children are in touch with
spirituality i don't mean they're
self-reflective i mean they're being
when when they're happy they are really
happy
you see the happiness is pure
and sometimes they're happy for no
reason they're just gurgling
and for me that is a spiritual quality
they might not know it they might not
know they're happy
they know self-reflection
self-reflection is actually
as a good human quality
it's necessary human quality but at the
same time it is the beginning of ego
without self-reflection we won't have
ego
you see
and self-reflection
is
is important for spiritual practices in
general or even for inquiry the way i do
it we do need to have self reflection
but
selfish is one capacity that
consciousness has but
but consciousness also can know itself
without self-reflection
can know itself by being that's that
that the english word gnosis comes from
you know on wazes and the way the greeks
say it is that i know myself by being
myself i'm not reflecting
it's like i am in in expanse a medium of
consciousness
and this medium aware of itself at all
points of itself
and it is this medium is speaking to you
so it doesn't need to reflect on itself
it sees through itself
it's a the whole medium is
is not just within my body is outside my
body do
so that's not self-reflection that is
known by being
which is the the the true spiritual
capacity that people need to
er develop
to
have a realization and that is actually
what those who are trying to refer to by
talk about taste because taste is more
intimate than seeing
if something is it's you know inside or
touch
or or touch is you have you have to
touch it mean you're really immediate
you're more
direct and the same thing with taste is
even more immediate it's inside you
you see while seeing is over there
you see
so immediacy
is a very important part of spiritual
all spiritual
experiences
there's no immediacy of experience which
means no it's beyond self-reflection it
is not a spiritual experience yet
and then this question comes from key
concrete007 at 55 i've become reflective
and decided to take dmt
not for recreational purposes but to
open my mind to fear and amazement
i've been an atheist all my life at one
point during my ayahuasca experience i
raised my hand skyward and said god
forgive me i'm no longer an atheist my
question what are your thoughts on the
controlled use of dmt or psychedelics in
general
good question
i know these days many people are
involved in
using
you know some of the substances to
access virtual realities and in fact
there are
you know some native
um
teaching in different
places where they use that
and um
i
tried those when i was in college lsb
and things like that and i had spiritual
experiences and openings and
what i remember from my experience
i did it several times you know in
the 60s and
early 70s
but then after
when i started having spiritual
experiences
on my own without them
i did not go back
to the using those substances and and i
was wondering about the other day why
didn't i
it's not like somebody told me
don't do it
it just dropped out of my mind and and
now
i'm not that interested but i do
hear about it from students from other
people that they experiment with these
and
some of them have good experience and
especially
for somebody who is
find it difficult to access a spiritual
dimension
it can can be i see it
helping them
do it once or twice it opened them up in
a way that they weren't being able to be
open and that way they
saw something about themselves very they
couldn't see before and that is really
helpful for their development
and evolution
so i think that way i've seen it being
useful that way
i wouldn't recommend that somebody use
it as their way of spiritual practice
unless they are part of some indigenous
tribe and they have their own
you know way of dealing with it
i find many of the people who we were
talking about earlier who with a
megaphone shout their toe out to other
people in such a manner that doesn't
have people welcoming their toe they
tend to have in common that their
insights were precipitated by their
private use of psychedelics so do you
see that psychedelics to inform one's
philosophy or ontology etc as removed
from a community is somehow
net negative in some manner or not as
pure
well it's not that you know it's more
like
comparing my experiences
from the 60s and 70s on psychedelics
from my later experiences was happens
more spontaneously
there is a difference in quality it's
not the same
the psychedelic gives it the
changes thing some way
that is
not how reality is exactly
when you experience
you know
one's raw
consciousness and and
it it has the possibility of opening up
but it also opens up to other things
that are not true you know it because
also can magnify our imagination
and that's why people have bad trips you
know
because it
could magnify anything
so um
i the way i think about it is that
some traditions
like the ayahuasca tradition in south
america for instance
they have developed a way of working
with it
that they use it for
you know
as part of their
spiritual practice
but i also seen some
americans who went there and
did that and they came back and their
spiritual access naturally was
got more narrow
hmm interesting see that goes back to
what i was referring to earlier about
path dependence so some people would say
no this lesson works and it works
ubiquitously but it also depends on
where you are one of the ways that i
like to conceptualize this i'm curious
if you i'm curious what your thoughts
are
is that i see some westerners taking on
eastern approaches and vice versa
somewhat uncritically and i wonder if
that's always a net benefit because to
me it's akin to installing max off force
installing mac software on your pc
you're going to get errors if it's not
compatible with how you grew up with
what your view is right now do you see
that i think there is a point there
occurred
in the sense that the
the eastern approach they have their own
world view
they're which is different from a
western world world view
for instance
um
both the indian spirituality and
buddhist spirituality
developed on being
free from samsara
right by the kosamsara which is the
ordinary world
and basically
because they believe in reincarnation
is that the idea is to not reincarnate
again
you want to be enlightened so they'll be
free from this world and not come back
again
and and the west we don't subscribe to
that kind of thing you know
incarnation coming back whatever you
know for me
i don't know if that's true or not
see so i don't look at spirituality that
way
i i look at spirituality that is to
make life as complete as deep as
possible
and that means something else for later
right
see and so
so
yeah so some people
adopt the eastern view of with all
their philosophical or
metaphysical perspective of
reincarnation and
and
you know and
leaving the world and
which which has in it a way of saying
that this world is
is no good this that's you're here
you see
i
myself
i don't know i mean i'm i don't know i
mean i i have some experiences of
incarnation whatever i don't know if
they're true or not if they're real or
not
and so i don't subscribe to that
so it's true if somebody who's watching
who takes on that like they're putting a
hat on
their brain
that
is just a hat on them it's not really uh
uh
naturally
arising inside within them
but spiritual but however if somebody
takes the spiritual tradition
and take the practices and learn to
connect to the truth of who they are and
then that is independent of the world
view
because you're just what you are at this
moment
but you are at this moment has nothing
to do with the past or the future so
you're not thinking of
all the
you're free of the world of you
basically any world of view
in that way it could be useful yes and
many i think have found it useful that
way
thank you sir
thank you for coming on to the program
and answering these questions spending
some time with me
it's been fun enjoyable talking together
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a
that is kurt jymungal it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you
you